[Music]
wait a minute you guys aren't the real
Avengers hope gives it away that is
spider-man homecoming it opens tomorrow
and is expected to pull in more than 100
million dollars as weekend Pamela
Matheson is here for that story and I've
seen it fantastic so good right in the
studio is banking on the new cast to
help put a fresh spin on this franchise
if you didn't man himself uh Malin who
told et on lines any director such a
different backdrop yeah anything we've
seen in the past the cast being so
diverse having a character exists where
there's other superheroes him being a
kid being in high school it's just an
endless list of differences Spidey is
just 15 years old in the newest version
for Marvel so enter the baby-faced
Holland the Brit was 20 years old during
filming Tobey Maguire the original was
25 he was followed by Andrew Garfield
there was 27 you get the call you're
gonna be in a Marvel movie you're gonna
be inspire man what was your reaction I
went absolutely nuts jumped out of it
was screaming and shouting I hope the
phone and then I proceeded to scream and
crying so I was extremely excited I was
like like I'm freaking out inside it
doesn't do a very good job in hiding it
and this time the Avengers are invited
for in the Marvel Universe and we're
seeing a completely different version of
spider-man Peter Parker is an intern for
Robert Downey's Tony Stark I can keep
that soon yeah dunfin me it's like not a
reboot yeah basically
and Aunt May's back played this time by
Oscar winner Marisa Tomei
she's very maternal she's always worried
about him but one thing will never
change
Spidey stunts will always be testified I
would go as far as they wanted me to go
until they would stop
[Music]
you